fin de la cumbre de la unión europea
durante dos jornadas en los líderes del
bloque discutieron sobre la crisis
migratoria en el viejo continente y
acordaron nuevas sanciones contra
belarús por usar como arma la entrada de
migrantes a europa en estación
instrumental y 6 nov migration
esto es una instrumentalización de la
migración para presionar políticamente a
la unión europea por eso mantendremos la
presión sobre el régimen de lukashenko
ya hemos propuesto la revocación de
visas para el régimen y sus aliados y
estamos listos para estudiar más
sanciones antes proxies no sólo contra
individuos sino que contra entidades y
compañías también individuales para el
software entities o companies ante los
ojos de la unión europea polonia también
ha cruzado una línea roja ya que el país
antepuso la ley nacional a la
intercomunitaria pero el bloque de los
27 asegura que está dispuesto a dialogar
en busca de una solución
política es importante gestionar este
tema políticamente y tener un diálogo
escuchamos el fuerte mensaje de varios
líderes con los esfuerzos para mantener
un diálogo político
y para escucharnos los unos a los otros
y entender cuáles son los problemas
exactos para conseguir soluciones is in
order to the league of solutions otro
tema central fue el alza de precios de
la energía para solucionar este problema
la ub planifica a corto plazo que los
estados inviertan en ayudas para los
hogares y a largo plazo establecer una
posible reserva estratégica de gas común
y estudiar el estado del mercado el
compromiso climático y la transición
digital también estuvieron sobre la mesa
finalizando la jornada los líderes
europeos aprovecharon para despedirse de
angela merkel con una ovación tras
ocupar el puesto de canciller de
alemania por 16 años
[Música]